ultr speaking is a collection of games
that are designed to train your brain to
help you speak better so in this video
I'm going to cover three ultr speaking
games and how you can play them so that
you can practice your speaking skills
build your confidence and speak with
more clarity on the fly my name is
Michael I'm a public speaking coach blah
blah blah I've worked with a lot of
awesome people and coached them on their
public speaking skills I even coached
Ali abdal on freestyle rapping but
that's a different video check that out
if that's interesting the point is that
I'm obsessed with this stuff I want to
figure out how people can feel more
confident and speak better now not in 6
months but now and so I'm going to show
you three games that are going to get
you to practice that right now the first
game I want to play is called rapid fire
analogies I'm just going to show you how
I play it and then we talk about what
it's what it's all about everything's
random by the
way a banana is like Scissors because it
cuts your potassium need in half a new
car is like babies because they both
have that fresh smell a mirror is like a
broken finger because it likely reflects
you not taking time to think a molecule
is like Monsters because when you look
deep inside it's kind of scary taxes are
like breaking your phone because it can
really frustrate you YouTube is like
working from home actually I am working
from home making
YouTube cool so couple rules in this
game number one did you say something
for every analogy number two were you
able to project re confidence in your
voice for every single rep and number
three did they make sense and when
you're starting out this game don't
worry about it making sense just worry
about making sure you say something for
every analogy so you can go more rounds
you can make it a lot faster let's just
give it one more go and then we'll move
on toilets are like tiny homes because
they take up a little bit of space
singing is like luck because it comes
from the gods alcohol is like the
Horizon because it can make you look
into the distance falling in love is
like so bubbles it can pop in a Flash
cleaning out the fridge is like a butt
it's smelly a treasure map is like a
road trip because it's all about
following directions diversity is like
pancakes because you can't have just one
kind a glazed donut is like a microphone
because I don't know goal setting is
like a judge because it's
harsh cool so notice you could say I
don't know when you don't know but this
game's about separating Confidence from
content meaning can you express yourself
with confidence even when you're not
sure what you're saying and I think it
quickens the brain I think it makes it
sharper with practice but uh that's just
my hypothesis my next favorite game is
called triple step triple step is really
fun let me just show you how it play how
to play it you just get a a title and
I'll give you a little speech on
it my source of inspiration comes from
Reading to be completely honest I read
not that much but I've read this book
The Dow day ching and that's been my
biggest inspiration most of my life I've
been hungry for like knowledge and the
to aing kind of s iated that with wisdom
it said stop being so controlling stop
chasing after goals and start start
having some teamwork with the universe
with the Dow with the way that things
are and it's a wild philosophy because
it basically says like like don't be a
police car chasing after everything kind
of just relax and and get on a trolley
and go with the flow of things it's very
it's very strange uh it's like a beard
it took a while to grow on me but with
time I found that I'm like controlling
as a result and uh I'm I'm it's like
getting a massage I'm just more relaxed
more at ease and it's all about letting
go of control and that for me brings a
lot of inspiration because my mind isn't
cluttered with news like a newspaper
it's just free to roam and as a result
ideas come naturally cool so that's
triple step as you can see like a lot of
on the-fly thinking but what this game
really trains is being able to have a
clear train of thought because the words
are design designed to distract you and
you're building the skill of focus can
you stay on message and integrate the
words on the fly if you want to see this
game in action like on Extreme settings
check out this video right here I
actually play in a sauna on Extreme
settings on like really really fast
settings and uh and it gets pretty wild
gets pretty heated CU I play with
Tristan and we're competing all right
the final game we're going to play today
is called conductor I love conductor
it's all about musicality it's all about
speaking like Breaking Free from
monotonous speaking and you're going to
catch on pretty quickly how it goes so
I'm going to give a speech again ah
books versus
movies like I said I love reading books
but um but movies are easier movies is
kind of like the Lazy Man's book and uh
a movie I watched recently was uh oh I
don't even remember that's that's the
problem with movies is you don't really
remember what you watch because there's
so much content there's a lot of content
on YouTube right now a lot on Netflix
and these content Wars are are just so
they're making content kind of more
forgettable so how do you stand out how
do you stand out whether in a book or a
movie how do you stand out with
originality I don't
know I don't know but Ryan Tran's doing
a really good job I've been watching him
a lot lately and I love what he's doing
on YouTube and it just like makes me
feel watching him makes me feel good
it's an amazing energy that he has and
maybe that's the originality maybe it's
not about the content as much as it is
about the individual behind
it cool so this game is all about
playing with energy and learning how to
vary your energy on the Fly because the
key to musicality the key to sounding
engaging is contrast so that means we go
up but we also go down and notice how I
can enter different moods on command man
there's a whole bunch of games that I
wish we could get into
uh but the beauty is you can get into
them you can play them for free at
ultraspa oh by the way by the way okay
right here we have this course uh called
the basics it's also completely free and
I if you want to get into ultr speaking
I can't recommend this enough this is a
practice driven video course so you're
not only going to get lessons on how to
play different games and what the basics
of Ting art you're also going to get an
opportunity to practice as well so make
sure you check that out if you want to
see other games or other gameplay let me
know thanks for watching I'll see you in
the next video